[Music]
june 18th pikes peak center colorado
springs colorado prepares
for the funniest show
on
earth
cool tune dude
yeah i don't think so
okay yeah here we go
this song sucks
[Music]
i'm talking about lame yeah totally
i i can change it
ah i can live with it if you can i can
live with it if you can
don't you remember you told me you love
me baby
[Music]
[Music]
baby
oh baby
[Music]
[Applause]
this week in feminism
[Music]
i mean yeah i hit him
like really hard but
he wasn't supposed to do anything about
it he went to the center and take it
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what i know
[Music]
[Music]
i was just checking to see if all my
rights were removed because of uh roe v
wade nope
still good it's still there still there
i mean a few more people have been you
know assaulted in a molotov cocktail
from uh yesterday but uh i it doesn't it
feels like everything is about the same
so we'll be talking not only about that
uh uh the reactions yesterday the
fallout uh and what we most likely see
taking place uh throughout the week uh
but we'll be i'll be sitting down here
today with douglas murray author of uh
the war on the west uh he is a brilliant
guy
also happens to be gay but that's not
all he is
so much more so much more and a bag of
chips is that still being used yes it is
yes in a bag bag of potato chips yes uh
and i do think man karen carpenter you
guys can uh you know what comment below
name that that film uh reference there
for people
how have
another question is again we're pinning
the top comments how has it affected
your life roe v wade something that
affects our life directly is what
happened with dave chappelle yesterday
and um you know it's actually sort of
providential that i didn't discuss the
conversation i had at starbucks
yesterday we were going to do that on
mug club with someone who
went on a tirade against dave chappelle
before this happened saying that he was
anti-trans and that she didn't like his
jokes about sexual assault well this is
what we're seeing right now we're seeing
a culture of violence because how long
can you go on accusing people of being
nazis accusing people of being racist
telling women that men want to remove
their rights of bodily autonomy before
people on the left start treating folks
like us
like actual nazis
you know what you're doing and this
isn't the first time i think something
black lives matter something something
barack obama that that election back
then and then i think there was a
pandemic and more riots going into the
la yeah yeah every time election season
rolls around every single time they gin
up riots and they're violent because
they cannot protest any other way what
do you mean by they i mean the left why
you got to do a left right thing okay
show me people on the right right now
with roe v wade being violent
you have to reach back to january 6 with
a guy with silly makeup come on it's not
the same it's not 9 11. so we're talking
about that more and douglas murray i'm
really looking forward to sitting down
with him uh of course if we get removed
because i have no idea what he's going
to say you can tune in monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern here uh on
rumble if you're on youtube so if we
don't tell you that we're not doing a
show
it means we're doing a show it's just
not here on youtube because we have no
idea when we'll be suspended and you can
just bookmark the page go check it out
of course mug club we'll be doing
another probably another hour with
douglas murray today
all right
we don't have him here uh gerald a so we
have in his place and we may keep him in
this place gerald b how are you sir
my he is stoic better personality though
well yeah charmer more i wouldn't say
more lively no easier at parties yes
more comfortable in his own skin right
and they and doesn't ruin everything
correct yeah yeah also doesn't double
dip no
gerald a double dips right gerald
just hovers doesn't even do the single
dip
and you're like well that's that's
polite it's very exciting that's polite
as a party guest and uh you know him you
love him uh we'll be talking more about
our dates because it relates to dave
chappelle but you go to livecutter.com
tour heat on the road all the time will
be announcing a major fall tour soon
dave landa how are you sir ahoy i'm good
i can't complain well you didn't get
assaulted on stage no not yet knock on
wood
no so i mean i've i've been but not
recently joke's on you that's faux wood
oh oh you're gonna get you're gonna be
raped yay i think that's how it works
something about rubbing your head and
they'll be like pointing out that's part
of his closer yes
you can expect more of that
atlatic.com tour enjoy him in person
so you watch this this is this is
something that's obviously near and dear
to our heart before we get to roe v wade
the dave john situation and there are
larger ramifications at play here than
just dave chappelle just like we talked
about this with chris rock and will
smith so before we show the clip this is
probably something i would you were on
top of immediately when it happened yeah
absolutely well like i've said it on the
show before i had opened for dave uh
before he went away
and then i opened for him when he came
back and it's just interesting to see
especially now his last special he
included an entire story about his trans
friend who committed suicide right
included in there and that wasn't good
enough and the reality is is that just
shows that even if you try
to give somebody what they want and to
try to in you know ingrain yourself into
their life and show a little bit of
empathy it doesn't matter right you will
never give anybody what they want right
they it would always be this narrative
of its anti-you comedy like scott
thompson uh from kids hall always said
it best like comedy is supposed to be
dangerous there's supposed to be an
element of that yeah but it's also
supposed to be a relief uh from
everything going on in society there's
supposed to be one thing we can look at
and a comedy that uh
a society that loses its sense of humor
just loses everything there's no reason
to even exist well his last special
before that wasn't even a comedy special
was about george floyd and went in
pretty hard on candace owens and she
wasn't all that upset hey how many
offended at all how many right-wing
extremists attacked dave chappelle on
stage we have a good a b test here
because he's gone after both sides and
really he's gone after the right for
much more of his career than the left i
mean at one point he was perceived as
being anti-white with comedy central and
that was something where they wanted to
step in and sort of take some creative
control that's not the only reason but
he walked away from 100 million dollar
contract so when you talk about being
bold and brave and i was talking with
this barista at starbucks i never go
there i ran out of coffee okay so hold
your comments
no you know what admonish me admonish me
i shouldn't have been in starbucks all
right you got it i should not have been
in starbucks the only reason i went was
because duncan they weren't taking cards
at the drive-thru
yeah like we only accept cash well i
hope you accept uh gold coins
yeah
duncan so i had to go to starbucks and
they were taught she was talking about
dave chappelle this younger barista and
she was saying i don't like his trans
jokes i don't i think that his jokes
about sexual assault i was you really
don't know do you that you know it's not
bold and brave to beat women for example
in a swim meet it's a brave move to walk
away from a hundred million dollars at
comedy central which dave chappelle did
he actually had skin in the game serious
game in the game and had friends take
his show yes and then the show went to
uh mencia and then the show went to
and i i think he and peel are brilliant
they're great but it was a it was a
similar there was a dark period yeah
between that yeah there was a dark
period between that he and peel were
brilliant but what are you talking about
that's a [ __ ] joke
that's [ __ ] my dick man it don't
work oh boy
hey there are seven words you can't say
on television like that's not yours yes
it is bro
yeah it's just it yeah it really was a
sad time but he had this brilliant show
and his friends you know a couple of his
friends still did the show they still
went with it and even though the
chappella show without dave there right
they really try to keep playing it and
and dave has always been
i think killing them softly is one of
the most brilliant stand-up specials you
can ever watch the guy's hilarious he
punches on all sides and it's very
personal and real and funny and good
he writes three hours of material a week
he gives everything that has been asked
of comedians that's the thing with dave
chappelle whether you agree with him or
not and i disagree with him on a whole
lot everything that is asked of a good
comedian dave chappelle has given and
then some he writes new material he's
very even-handed that no side is safe
with dave chappelle he's not
mean-spirited he treats his staff well
he treats his fans well everything that
you could ask of dave chappelle he has
given you he's gracious to new comics
he's uh well there you go yeah trying to
use openers look
it's true though you don't see that with
everybody oh believe me i know yes
try opening for someone in lancaster
pennsylvania who promises you nothing
more than a ride back to new york and
then leaves you there oh good people
yeah yeah that's a sweet site that's
when you see a six-figure check and then
they hand you 300 bucks you're like guys
yeah okay thanks i got it oh thank you
this is enough to buy rope yes perfectly
probably not enough no maybe i don't
know maybe if you do a nice uh if you do
like nice sailors not oh yeah not roping
i don't know about knots i'm not a
nautical expert
all right so this happened like we just
talked about with dave chappelle i
wanted to set that up uh because
this affects us personally but it also
affects you personally
uh yesterday at i believe was the
hollywood bowl um
dave chappelle was attacked on stage now
hold on a second hold on a second
spoiler alert it has a happy ending
because a protester got the [ __ ] kicked
out of him not protester let's call
these people if they are violent thugs
someone storms the stage to try and
attack dave chappelle here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
also the hollywood bowl not the place to
do this no
is that will smith
[Applause]
that's a shame yeah oh that's a shame
let me be really clear about my position
on this if that person
never walked again and had to sip his
food through a straw i'm not saying
that's ideal i don't wish it upon them
it wouldn't be an injustice you and i
both know when we are when you're on
stage
especially when someone comes up with a
replica gun as he did you can't know the
intent you absolutely have to eliminate
that threat if someone is storming a
stage violently you are uh
you're taking that risk that you could
lose your life because you are putting
someone else
in fear of theirs just like if you
mugged someone at knifepoint i wasn't
going to stab him you know what the
victim can't know that
so uh i think that that's a
a happy middle ground
i don't know what kind of injuries were
sustained but you know i'm hoping that
there were some well also i mean clearly
it was self-defense dave chappelle was
attacking you with doing his stand-up
show where you charge the stage but
words are violence oh that's right so is
silence
yes you know what else's violence is uh
what they did to him that's great yes
actual violence yeah they say all lives
matter and uh this is my proof that it
they don't yes no that's true i i
honestly i i don't want to just pretend
like i could
care less about the guy no these are the
he is the exact well you know this
because we've look look and by the way
you can go to lottery.com
you're going to be in actually i don't
know if this is a good time to play it
copycats uh this week in springfield
missouri lincoln nebraska so you know
what uh go out and support dave because
he's going to be on stage and you know
this too i'll be by the way i haven't
done a comedy club in years i'm doing
for the first time in uh july whatever
that week is the 18th or 23rd in spokane
washington it's not on the website dude
my friend adam runs it it's great well
but it's the reason it's really tough to
secure those places yeah so uh we've had
to take precautions good luck i'll be in
spokane this summer you can just find
spokane comedy club if you want to go
see it i'm working out some material for
a fall tour and you'll be doing these
dates this weekend you know i told you
about this before when i was doing less
and le before even the pandemic on stage
and i was saying well look
you'll kind of experience it there's a
different security risk and a lot of
people think because a lot of people out
there want to act like martyrs on both
the left and the right that it's just
well okay you're blowing it out of
proportion you know now
yes
i'm surprised that that guy got that
close that would never happen at one of
our shows oh
15 years ago i remember going into like
the deep south to perform yeah and uh
just what bouncers would do to a heckler
yeah you know before really people had
camera phones it was fun to watch it was
yes and uh it was it but it said that
this is what it's come to there's that
people who are just simply trying to go
up on stage make jokes have fun
everybody around you when you stand up
and scream or shout or get upset without
even this right they hate you yeah they
hate you you make everyone uncomfortable
you ruin their entire night it's awful
just shut your mouth and watch the show
we even had to deal with a positive
heckler one time
every remember our show was it uh
was it was it evansville or was it uh is
it covered it was in detroit remember
every time everybody was like i love you
we were like okay good calm down no i
just want you to know we're like
stop and then someone the same person
that when you came out so they're taking
out your greatest fan you're like i
don't give a [ __ ] yeah it's like at this
point i don't care but i appreciate the
sentiment right no it's it's like i like
your shirt you're like i understand i'm
doing a show yes exactly it's like this
isn't this isn't church yes you can't
talk back this is not an interactive
show it's not a film where you like yell
out that he's behind you and i get
stabbed what's so required to timing
especially in my act like a lot of my
stuff like i i i'm not dirty at all but
i i'm dark and i talk about my true life
experiences yeah i need to create
attention that's the idea so careful
with your life experiences because it
might trigger someone else who had
similar experiences oh that's true they
might they might attack me yeah the ptsd
and then you might have ptsd and it's a
never-ending ptsd cycle well it's i'm
white it doesn't matter exactly yeah
privileged yeah living up growing up in
detroit being arrested 13 times you
wouldn't know anything about uh anything
about hardship right i can only have pp
yes
tsd
it is but this is where we and we're
going to get to the protests and the
prediction that i made yesterday how
look i'm not nostradamus it's just it
always happens when you say
this person is a nazi this person is a
fascist right they they use the term
yesterday sexual fascism by the way in
the comments no one actually made a case
as to what sexual fascism is or
certainly how this roe v wade being
overturned just just having to do with
the third trime first trimester and
state uh regulations would affect anyone
uh
in a sexually fascist way it's so silly
i don't even know how to say it but you
know what i'm still willing to hear a
case but you can say sexual fascist nazi
only so long look if there were if
hitler were actually here no one would
fault us for punching him in the face no
but they want everyone to believe that
you are hitler that donald trump is
hitler that now dave chappelle is hitler
and so it makes it justifiable to treat
those people in humanely no one's going
to watch it change my mind and say hey i
should go out and kick the ass of every
single blue haired lesbian on campus i
if i had a dollar for every jewish
comedian i know who's been called hitler
in the last three years he should retire
it's like do you even know who you're
talking to and then the jewish comedian
would shake you down for it i'm entitled
to a piece yeah
come on his agent that was at my expense
how about 10
15. what do you say
i want to drink when i say 10 that's on
top of the uh 30 that already goes but
that's uh that's the transaction fee
that's out of my hands i get the
deposits
for pr what now you're complaining oh
with all the punching and the joking
into complaining the point is don't
assault comedians don't assault people
who happen to be pro-life and don't want
babies being killed whether you think
it's a life or not how about we
this is it it's all coming from one side
that's why they want to make january 6th
such a big deal and it wasn't anywhere
near as violent
as you saw not only as violent as just
last night and it's only going to get
worse so everyone else out there by the
way i'm not calling you to violent keep
your head on a swivel keep your head in
the swivel right now because i predict
that this is going to get going to get
worse and i really really hope that
people see dave chappelle
yeah situation i hope they understand
that it's not just a comedian on stage
we have to deal with the threat directly
but it's about silencing all of you and
we just can't we just
not another inch not one more inch well
this is the problem with we're talking
about collateral damage it's this it's
the extremism it's not collateral damage
when it's just the intent oh yeah well
that's true
yeah it's a fancy way of putting it yeah
i don't think dave saw him running the
stage was like i hope i don't i hope i
don't end up as collateral damage
literal direct target yes uh
yeah it
it's so funny because so many people do
point out the black kkk sketch that he
did in the early 2000s and it's almost
pointed out so much to the point that
it's hacky but it's insane because it's
real now yes you're calling him a white
surprise that's just a nazi
and at one point it was a parody because
it was so absurd it couldn't possibly
exist right in our culture and this is
when i was 23 i know it wasn't that long
ago i know the the the way that we've
fallen apart as a society in such a
small time is mind-boggling it really is
and it's because the extremists have
gone so far and where they're constantly
being fueled they're constantly being
fueled by media everybody else
justifying their actions and because
i've been placated of course too many
people have been oh i'm scared about
that you know we'll talk more about that
with douglas murray because i know he
has strong opinions on that so how do we
get here well let's start with look
before you get to dave chappelle let's
start with the representatives uh so
roe v wade obviously this is something
that was the leak which we'll talk about
we have uh there there's some now some
new clues as to who i put together
yeah well you know i appreciate it but
it's still you can't take a towel with
you everywhere i know we're a snuggie we
do it kill you to wear a snuggie
now uh elizabeth warren let's look at
the kind of unhinged rant that you hear
from our representatives and see if when
they talk about donald trump inspiring
violence well okay you see what
elizabeth warren said you saw what aoc
said and then you see actual violence
right you see actual violence take place
last night here's elizabeth warren the
uh
well as far as i can remember the most
famous non-native american
yesterday ranting about roe v wade this
is what
the republicans have been working toward
this day
for decades
they have been out there plotting
carefully cultivating these supreme
court justices
so they could have a maturity on the
bench who would accomplish something
that the majority of americans do not
want 69 where's the manager
across this country red states and blue
states old people and young people want
roe versus wade to maintain this number
two and we we need to know and we have a
right this will fall
this will fall on those who have been
raped this will fall on mothers who are
already struggling to work three jobs oh
yes he's able to support the children
they have
well i am here because i am angry
what else is new here
because the united states congress can
change all of this
gosh she just moves like old white men
dance at weddings you know
she just moves like an old lady this is
the youthful exuberance you can expect
from today's democratic establishment a
couple of things first off the most
generous estimate is 1.5 cases when
you're talking about uh abortions are
the result of rape this comes from usa
today and that's very generous okay i
think that's uh uh
overlay a yeah overlay usa today 1.5
that's that includes rape and incest
also interesting that she talks about
how this will fall on black women this
will fall on poor women considering if
you understand the history of planned
parenthood margaret sanger eugenicist
and a racist they deliberately set up
shop in black neighborhoods and targeted
poor people because they saw it as a
form of eugenics so this is something i
guess maybe she doesn't necessarily know
our own history and isn't it always
convenient
when they bring up and i'm not saying
that there are no women like this
just to be clear
but the vast majority
are not the upstanding citizen who is
the upstanding mom who's working three
jobs every day and already has a family
uh and simply can't afford another child
therefore she needs an abortion that's
the scenario they always paint the
upstanding person who has made no
irresponsible decisions who is not what
we're talking about bodily autonomy not
in charge of her own sexual decisions
could have not prevented this in any way
even though she is of course responsible
and took all proper countermeasures
and happens to have a family already
existing and was raped therefore needs
an abortion that's that's who this is
going to fall upon says elizabeth
non-native american warren
do you buy it
is anyone buying it that wasn't dana
carvey
[Laughter]
i'm going to be the master of the senate
so
i i don't uh i don't care for i just was
waiting for her husband to grab a beer
out of the fridge and just be like no no
that's enough no
you haven't seen a young person since
1976
um yeah i don't uh i think the the issue
is at least as far as i learned
yesterday
is that it's going to the states
and people are misinterpreting this at a
massive level nothing's going to change
really in your day-to-day life because
the challenge was that the states were
regulating abortions in the first
trimester which wrote that's the only
thing that roe v wade expressly forbid
against and so since i went to the
supreme court they had to say is this
actually good law though do states have
the right just like other states have
the right to put their restrictions or
no later on an abortion it's not really
going to affect you
at all it simply recognizes that
abortion is not a constitutional right
and that's not what roe v wade ever
recognized unfortunately it was
interpreted that way i don't want to get
too nerdy you can go to yesterday's show
but here's the thing you see these kinds
of reactions uh from the elected
representatives and we'll get to the
riots in a second we have a montage for
you but of course it ended up becoming
violent last night i don't know i know
what who could have possibly seen this
coming here's yesterday's show
and if we don't have enough votes to
pass it now
we get everybody on the record and then
we take that to the public in november
we've got less than 200 days until
election day roe versus wade and that's
the reason for that
is intimidation
it's trying to scare people they're
trying to gin up riots and protests
right now so that people stay home and
don't vote or they're trying to convince
enough people out there that they're
right as extreme as they are believing
that you know kids should be put on
puberty blockers this is what your
former vice president said that
affirming your child's gender meaning
not their gender is one of the most
important things you can do they're
trying to say look at how extremist the
right is they're trying to remove your
right to abortion let's make sure that
message is heard up until and including
elections this isn't any different than
the playbook where kamala harris said
they should keep rioting and of course
you see it and just like clockwork you
see the protests and you know it's going
to get violent because
it's never not
ah
i also tweeted about it two nights ago
just to be clear and i don't say this
say look how good i am at predictions
it's so that you guys can take it to the
bank i want you to be able to observe
the patterns where dave chappelle
shouldn't be a surprise i want you to be
able to keep your head in a swivel and
be on guard and protect yourself when
you see decisions like this taking place
or when you see for example the 2020
election most free and most fair of all
time i want you to understand
that you could be in danger that's why i
tell you beforehand
and i'm not in the business of making a
lot of predictions this is one in which
i felt 100 confident two days ago on
twitter i wrote that the leaker of the
draft will undoubtedly be held as a hero
by the left it's a clear intimidation
tactic to pressure justices and uh that
of course the left will respond as they
always do when things don't go their way
with violence and destruction you can
follow me on twitter to see more of
those because now you're not you know if
you try and hit the follow button your
cursor doesn't go
and then follow vox
uh this happened yesterday uh of course
uh the riots after we broadcast in the
morning
just here look these aren't protesters
let's watch
[Music]
[Applause]
oh good
hey remember when the left was talking
about january 6th that we need to
respect our officers and honor them
not these officers no no that's a white
supremacist officer right there
i mean he's an olive tone supremacist
sure he's a little asian
and the other one's a little asian
[Music]
[Applause]
you're surrounding a guy look at that
bear spray
yeah
why would you go i know it's like that
worst person i know you're just shitty
they just sound like demonic banshees
well that's all it is is there's some
rage inside of you something you haven't
dealt with mixed with the fact that
you're an idiot right that makes you run
out and behave like this and who could
ever possibly insinuate that those
people are not pro-life and of course
they're also not that's not all you're
seeing you're seeing the violence in the
streets you're going to see it get worse
i guarantee you and of course this is
going to probably play up to the
election that's what they want you
because it it serves to highlight now it
could backfire because the left is seen
as a party of of not respecting rule of
law and you particularly see it with
latino americans in the recent polling
which we talked about yesterday but they
want this to serve as a highlight like
with the pandemic they want something
they can point to every single day going
into an election going the republicans
want to take your freedoms away and it's
not just these protests you are seeing
people online of course uh calling for
actual
violent insurrection on social media
don't take my word for it
if they actually do this yeah
that would be the time where rioting
would be okay i got the pitchforks you
get the gas and the torches
let's
do that because
you're not forcing
no
no yes we're not going to force you to
carry a child to term also instead of a
blow torch might suggest a toothbrush
while you're getting the gas do you want
to get an application at the station yes
yes perhaps you could work yeah that is
you know that's the person who grossly
abuses the take a penny leave a penny
bin oh yeah he definitely he's taking a
nickel yeah he brings his own cardboard
rollers
why
it doesn't affect whatever yeah it just
none of this if the fact that you can be
this angry about something that's not
directly affecting you in the moment
just shows me that you have no problems
maybe that's the issue with an extremely
free country is you it's oh we have it
so good we have to invent stuff to be
enraged about right well and here's the
thing i know people say well that's just
one random extremist again i present oh
yeah so many random years of extremists
so one random yeah one random exception
yeah it's this occasion but let's bring
up our main weather breaks right a
mainstream publication with uh nbc
universal vox one of the subsidiaries
it's uh ian how do you pronounce is it
ian milheiser i've only ever seen his
name written millhiser
milheiser milheisser milk houser i don't
know so this is from vox wrote seriously
shout out to whoever the hero was within
the supreme court who said
[ __ ] it let's burn this place down so
this isn't again we're not talking about
fringe elements you were talking about a
fringe element that by the way is not
even conservative when you're talking
about january 6 and wasn't even as
violent as just last night to be clear
the only person who was seriously
who was killed was a protester
now
this is what's happening right the right
we've talked about this the right is
upset over the leak because it's a crime
the left is upset over the fact that you
know you might have to go to colorado to
get an abortion well into the third
trimester and um well actually speaking
of leaks we were going to say we had
some but it looks like uh am i seeing
that yeah on cnn right now they have an
exclusive it seems like they may have
found the leaker this is cnn breaking
news
let's see
who's that it's a head shot of
tubing
all right that's enough cut it cut it
cut it tube
damn it cut the audio tim cut the audio
damn it [ __ ] sorry
wow
his own headshot
oh that guy does his leak stuff the most
trusted name in news i know
sorry about that yeah well you know what
sorry it doesn't we're live
wow
so let's move on here we have some other
representatives uh when we talk about
people on the left you have daniel
ulfelder a candidate for florida a.g he
wrote it's time for revolution we have
some other leftist groups all references
available at loudwrathcrowder.com it is
our moral imperative to show up and stop
the continuing slide into explicit
fascism by all means at our disposal and
then there's another one liberals will
march and chant their way
right to fascism peaceful protests
aren't enough rage and
riot there you go rage and riot hey you
know what this is where you see you know
what fascism is
is if i am here on this program
and we have to be careful just in using
the term line in the sand because the
overlords at big tech might interpret
that as a call to violence when they
actually allow
real calls to violence oh is that rage
and riot i you know i thought at first i
was like is it is it allegorical i don't
know because it says peaceful protests
aren't enough
rage and riot i don't know yeah it's up
to your interpretation exactly and i
don't know about the the the uh
blowtorch and pitchforks what he meant i
assumed that that was figurative yeah i
do too yeah
looks like he brushes his teeth with a
pitchfork yes he does yeah exactly
what you mean this isn't a water pick no
no no no the american got that's not a
water pick
i wear a hood in the house yeah
so look i want you guys to uh i want to
see where you are what you're like for
me the line in the senate is a the
ministry of truth honestly that to me is
is is far worse than what's going on
here with these rights of the supreme
court i hope that rule of law is
enforced but that is scarier because
guess what it will make it so that
people like us can't even criticize
violent actions and we are directly
affected like i said go to
lateralcrutter.com tour dave is going to
be in lincoln nebraska this weekend
there are other shows i'll be in spokane
washington in july and uh
big big tour in the fall costs us many
many many many many thousands in
security because of exactly what you're
seeing but you know what i think it's
almost not we're almost obligated to not
stop
you have to we have to what we're going
to do live in our house so you lock
ourselves down for a year and a half
that worked like a charm all right you
know what two years
you can because we're going to bring him
in um and i don't want you to have to
so you know what you can go take your
your potty break yeah if you have to
yeah like the tube and uh let's go is he
is he here he's coming in studio yeah
we'll get him in all right the author
here uh douglas murray we're about to
bring him on i'm looking forward to it
[Music]
all right as you can see by the
microphone positioning when i do this
that means it's a guest in studio uh
this next gentleman you can find him uh
on twitter at douglas k murray this is
his uh newest book the war on the west
it's got a little bit of a michael
crichton feel to it uh and he is a
columnist at the new york post and the
sun uh and what is hate uh mr douglas
murray i should say what is an associate
editor at spectator that seems like one
of those that's not a that's not a
[ __ ] term is it it's it's a slightly
[ __ ]
it is it's a roving role it's not it's
it's you could sort of do what you like
with it okay so roving and what have you
yeah uh that was when i was a fox news
contributor i found out that that just
meant uh they didn't want cnn to have me
they're like i was like what do i do
they said well just don't appear
anywhere else and we'll give you money
and i said okay and that's what means
contributor i didn't know this
i thought i had to contribute which i
didn't um for people who don't know and
i want to get into a few things that i
just find uh very interesting as far as
your point of view but what's this book
about the war in the west specifically
the war on the west is a sort of
culmination of three books i've written
starting with a strange death of europe
about migration then the madness of
crowds which was about all the crazy
stuff going on with trans and women's
rights and gay rights and all that stuff
and then this is this is a sort of
culmination of it which is just
basically my best attempt to try to
explain what i think is actually going
on in our time which is essentially a
war on everything that's ours
and an admiration and a love of
everything that isn't so that you know
we admire all traditions apart from our
own
uh the cool thing to do is to like love
things from other places and to hate
everything from our own
civilization yeah so that you know
we're now i i do it in four parts the
war on white people which i think is an
absolute catastrophe waiting to happen
where you tell the majority population
that they're appalling and have nothing
to be said for them and they have no
reason to be prepared
as an obscenely white person i am
absolutely white yes i mean i'm i'm
english and scottish yes no i mean i
mean yeah it's as
bad as it comes also and you i don't
know if you do you qualify as a ginger
not quite not quite no but blue eyes but
if i sought from minority status yes
but
the the basically i mean i think that
this this thing of right only one group
you're allowed to be racist about and
that's white people uh so i'd describe
that the war on white people
the war on western history which is
obviously just we decided to ransack
everything in our past take it all down
all the heroes there's no one left and
completely rewrite all western history
to say it's only about slavery racism
and colonialism because of course the
rest of the world did nothing wrong at
all in history no i mean i don't know if
you've seen they're uh they're going
gangbusters in north africa absolutely
yeah um and better and better yes and uh
then the third one is the war on western
religion which is
not just our christian religion but
the secular religion as well i mean the
war on enlightenment values which is
just unbelievable and some people might
not realize just how advanced that is
and then the war on western culture
where just every single thing that's
been produced from
the buildings to the art the music of
the west is also just looked at through
this
anti-racism lens you know it's all
terrible because it's created by those
by people who are guilty of those three
terrible things being white being male
and being dead yes and as you know
it's particularly unforgivable to die
um because none of the critics who
attack the dead white males will ever
experience that i thought you're going
to say if you're a kamikaze
let's show a camera that's more we'll
get into the morality sense but i
thought you were going to say being
white being male being straight
well that's obviously a particular sin
yes um yes i mean it's an abnormal state
state of affairs exactly which um
unforgivable well if we're going we're
talking about sort of the birth of
modern western civilization if we're
going back to even like rome you know
lots of gay stuff
for sure yeah yeah and for my times yes
i've heard talking the greeks uh the
island of lesbos when i was we were
talking about this recently the history
um
very different historical lesbians it's
not just a bunch of you know masculine
women who shop at orvis uh a few years
ago
a few years ago there was a channel five
documentary in the uk it's not our
finest channel and um they did it
is that channel four or six is that your
finest channel i don't know
it's the last channel
and they made a documentary called the
lesbians go mad in lesbos and uh they
the whole ship of lesbians landed on the
isle of lesbos as if they were going to
commune with their place of origin
because of course the poor locals just
like this horror they live in a very
charming island and suddenly these women
are going waving dildos in the streets i
know i just imagine there's some
beautiful you know sun-kissed
mediterranean woman oiling herself on
the beaches and then just someone runs
and crushing a natty ice can like let's
do this oh god yeah america it was
basically that or the
the british are here i don't know were
they were they english or i would
imagine that most americans most of the
worst tourists are british i'd like to
think really oh yeah sadly yeah well
because we always hear about from the
brits about how the worst tourists are
americans
yeah but we do violence better i think
that's true yeah mindless violence yeah
well there's nothing like a good soccer
riot exactly except we have good hockey
rides in canada we always knew when i
was raised in montreal if the canadians
won the stanley cup it would be a riot
right if they lost which was always in
my lifetime they also would rise
um so okay i wanna because you just
covered a lot of ground there let me ask
you this off the bat because i know
people watching will have a question
this you define yourself
or i have heard you describe yourself i
don't want to miss as a
a christian atheist or an atheist
christian
right yeah what does that mean
well it means i'm not a believer uh in
god or at least i find it very hard to
believe in god i'd say maybe agnostic is
better
but obviously i'm a christian because i
was born in a christian civilization a
christian country brought up a christian
so i mean you might there are people who
lose their faith or don't have faith and
are jewish or muslim but that's not the
same thing as a christian atheist
right what i was going to say because
with you know for example jews you can
be a jew through religion through faith
through ethnicity or through culture
sure whereas
christianity is primary it's a you know
decision the idea of salvation the idea
of making a decision yeah
so that's one thing i know and look i'm
not trying to start this in a
contentious way but i know some people
will take seems to be as contentious as
you like honestly i can take it well i i
know uh but i do
reputationally uh no i i i see it as
someone who's
not necessarily a
christian believing in the in the
literal sense the way that all persons
do but a christian sympathizer like
you're talking about found how it acts
as the foundation for western
civilization the judeo-christian values
as opposed to the edgy atheists who
would just say uh well if i need a god
to tell me not to murder or steal sure
then uh i mean i've known all the ag
atheists as you call them and i mean i i
just think it's absurd not to concede
the fact that
much of what we have in
america like britain canada is derived
from christian ethics right christian
ideas and why deny that i mean you might
not believe it but you shouldn't deny it
because it's it's obvious i mean what
what a human right but a kind of
derivation of a form of spilt
christianity
there's no reason to have human rights
they're not self-evident no um
so i think that you know you should just
concede these things where they're true
and and even if they're against your
interests and obviously the atheists
against their interests very often but
but nevertheless and and i also say that
it's important to concede this because
you should try to work out i think
whether you're
whether you want to engage in sawing off
a branch of a tree that you're sitting
on yeah and um a certain amount of
atheism does consist of that i think
yeah um
and i think it's the like i've always
said it's it's not the extremes where
people say if i need a god to tell me to
not murder well first off that's also
not necessarily universal what we do
murder is not killing right we define
murder separate from killing but what we
define as murder is just the byproduct
of killing in some other countries but
what about the other things like you
know not committing adultery what about
like you know for example you know any
type of like saudi arabia allowing women
to drive you know things like that
they're not universal values and that's
often taken for granted but i think some
people would
would just say well okay there's it's
tough to say christian atheists just
they would define it as
atheists but who's christian sympathetic
maybe i mean if i was jewish it would be
more straightforward because i'd just
be a practicing jew who didn't believe
well inside you know he would be born
jewish economically you know it would be
like let's say you converted to judaism
you know because you had a a
lady who was jewish but then you left
her and then you left but you called
yourself jewish it's like well but
you're not jewish
racially well ethnically yeah i mean
christianity is obviously a different
matter
but i just i just think that if you
also if you if you not only recognize
that it's where you've inherited some of
your ideas or many of your ideas from
but also ideas that you like
right why would you go to war with them
i mean um this is this was a position i
arrived at some years ago philosopher
roger scrutin is a great friend he he
also writes this at the very least don't
war on it
um why would you war on something that
you whose products you like
yeah um
so i do have a slightly heretical
atheist standpoint
okay did you always feel this way with
christianity no no i was a christian
no i'm saying did you always feel like
it had ideas that you liked oh yeah of
course well i mean i like this is one of
the things i said in the war on the west
is i mean i like the civilization i'm
from right i like the culture i'm from
i'm more than likely i love it
and i don't think it has to be
apologized for um i think it's very
unusual
in historic terms as well as in the
world today
and
we would be very very stupid if we
assumed that the kind of
civilization that we like
is by any means the default civilization
it just isn't i mean
you know that is interesting actually
you bring that up that it's very uh it's
very atypical historically for
lack of a better term the winning
culture the win well really look at the
british empire right the world's
predominant superpower you let your
number one draft pick get away we left
you guys one century to become the only
superpower the next sorry but you know
sooner or later we got to fly the coupe
uh that being said when people talk
about the united states being an evil
empire
i always find it odd when they say you
know we just we need to stop with the
nation building it's too expensive hold
on a second if people look to the
british empire uh it's not expensive
it's profitable that's what an empire is
you yes take the resources we're the
only country who uh go in and then
apologize for not doing a good enough
job that's why i went into iraq and uh
gave all the oil contracts to the french
which i don't understand
i don't know why i don't know why we
didn't just take it that's the one thing
i don't know if you uh in the uk you
know what i've talked about this with
donald trump he forced people to pay
attention by saying things that were
reasonable and the media would say was
offensive so i don't know if you
remember his quote where he said i would
only go if we take the oil and the music
can you believe he said we would take
the oil and people at home are like yeah
we're not yeah that's i mean that is
where i thought it was a war for oil
that is the norm historically and uh
it's it's only us that thinks it's um
it's unusual and hard and i mean
as a there's a graph in one of stephen
pinker's books about um average
average deaths by violence in societies
and shows you know i mean as i pointed
out in this book contrary to the sort of
western idea that you know you have um
you know you have guilty people in the
west and everyone else is innocent
including you know all native people
they're always innocent if you look at
the stats on it like
um
60 more percent of like in native
populations among tribes people in
africa and elsewhere the males die
violent deaths yes this is compared to
like a small single digit percentages of
males dying violent deaths in europe in
the 20th century like in our worst
century right so
a good portion of those i don't know if
you know this uh it was from from
nagging
so it's sort of yeah from nagging from
the wife it died yeah
it starts with them boiling the people
unaware of that yeah i know it throws
off the statistics but yeah i make sure
for the audience that it was
um no no it's a very good point when
people talk you know that goes to the
native american idea of giving people
say give the land back like for example
i think i don't know if it was the black
hills there was a specific area where
they were talking about giving the land
back and i did some research into i go
well which tribe
turned by four or five tribes who by the
way were killing and slaving raping
scouting so who do you give it back it's
like the conquistadors point i mean
obviously conquistadors did some
terrible things but the society they
walked into was not heavenly no do you
know how many conquistadors there were
kind of there was only a few hundred
yeah it was only a few hundred so do the
math it was all of the other enslaved
and pillaged and oppressed people who
said we're going to take our chances
with the guys in the shiny hats and the
and i don't if you saw but just the
other day they found another pilot you
know sacrificed bodies somewhere in them
in central america and it's a sort of
reminder of something that people in
america have forgotten which is these
these sort of allegedly you know more
native more rights to the lands people
um
you know they weren't great and i don't
if you saw but like a year ago the
california school board had this had
this thing where they got in religious
education lessons they they got the kids
to do chanting to the aztec gods yeah i
write a bit about it a bit it was
fantastic because they were like oh um
you know very unpronounceable name um uh
make us warriors for social justice you
know i looked up the relevant god and it
was a god of child sacrifice yes
sacrifice a child in order to uh throw
off the chains of systemic racism yes
well this seemed to me i mean i thought
and also if this god was actually true
and was summoned from the dead very
surprised the california school board
asked for him and i know you're sort of
an agnostic atheist christian so
sympathizer but uh in the christian
worldview if you're praying to the god
who sacrifices children that's a demon
right yeah so uh but that's just you
know i don't i you know i don't wanna i
don't want to get to get off on
technicalities generally speaking as
christians gods who require you know
regular sacrifice you know the blood of
children
you're probably praying to the wrong guy
absolutely and um
we have we have got this very weird view
in the west that
that it is just us that do bad things
right and the rest of the world is it
sort of it was something that really
sort of started in the 18th century you
can blame him that that that other
people by the way people like him didn't
know what people were like beyond europe
he'd never gone further in switzerland
right and he had all these views on um
you know native peoples there were
actually people who followed rousseau's
beliefs i give an example of a french
crew on a ship they they found some
maori people and because they followed
rousseau they believe that the locals
are going to welcome them they all get
butchered and eaten yes and um and they
they're the ones that get away think
less of rousseau afterwards i can
imagine yeah that would there would be a
disappointment we were told they were
going to welcome us with honey and
virgins and they killed us all later
well one sadomasochistic genocidist
doesn't spoil the bunch no um and also
you shouldn't tar them all we know that
no exactly just because exactly just
because
yeah i know this is one cannibalistic
episode right now exactly it's an
episode yeah it's like it's the
temporary cannibal plea it's
i was look i was temporarily a cannibal
i'm no longer your honor and i think i
should be free to go well good enough
for me
um which brings me to my you know my
question actually i think you've already
answered i was going to say notice you
don't say like like muslim atheist and
uh that's largely because half of you
would have to kill the other half
uh
muslim atheist uh is is is trickier
there are there are some now when i
first started writing about islam about
20 years ago
i was told there was an event at a
university in london where somebody
stood up and said at an event i'm um i
was born a muslim but i'm a non-muslim
now and the whole went places like
bananas right and the uh the event had
to be called off because everyone
started attacking each other i can
imagine by now by the way interestingly
enough by the last five years or so i've
discovered actually it's not uncommon at
events for people to publicly or
certainly afterwards
you know sort of semi-publicly announced
that they are a non-muslim now right
they're a muslim atheist and that
actually gives me some hope because it
suggests that people will are more free
to leave the religion if they're in the
west than they used to be right and that
actually the sort of freedoms other
people enjoy in the west to go in and
out of religions as they see fit could
actually be allowed to apply to muslims
as well which is all yeah no
a lot of people convert to islam in the
united states in prison
that's true just so you know they say
like ah it's one of the fastest growing
religions yes if you count cell block d
i
i have a friend in the uk a journalist
called julie burchill and she some years
ago said um
we're talking about the issue of women
who convert to islam which is a very
interesting case i don't understand it
well she said she said douglas they're
the same stupid [ __ ] what write
letters to prisoners who've mass
murdered people and asked to marry them
yes there is a certain type of woman
yeah who writes to convicts
and wants to be their lover so it's the
same thing yeah i read that i read it to
female inmates but that's just it's just
the conjugal visits i just want to put a
smile on their face well of course now
we know from the trans prisoners that we
were told wouldn't it wouldn't ever
happen well that women can be
impregnated by fellow female inmates we
were we had that episode removed from
youtube where we discussed that we
discussed that story and they removed it
so now we have to be careful because
they said uh oh you can't do that
because that would insinuate that's like
one second i didn't say all trans people
are inmate rapists
i said this one was yeah it's like the
woman with a penis who um screwed the
wheelie bin in sheffield in the north of
england the other day did you see that
the wheelie bin oh yeah what even is it
trash can oh is there a trash can you
call it a wheelie bin yeah she did
and um well i don't know is that a term
in in england no really yeah and but
it's not
commonly
uh put together with the word sex toy
right exactly or her people don't
usually have sex with it
most people don't right they just take
the trash out in it and they leave it
alone yeah but um requires some outside
the wheelie been thinking but this
this uh
this um this um woman with a penis
indeed did indeed use the william as a
sex toy and
in case youtube is watching
that's that's fine well it's not
entirely out of the purview of its role
as a deposit box it's it's not very uh
ladylike behavior that's true but it is
a woman doing it yeah stephen someone
debate you over you know this small fact
of the [ __ ] so let me ask you um about
this because actually i do want to talk
about islam and in the west a little bit
then we can kind of talk about not just
islam in the west uh but also uh you
know you sort of talked of of
i mean if people want to use the term
sort of original sin but really implicit
bias and the idea of the sins of our
fathers and slavery and that to me has
been very interesting there have been uh
quite a few pieces of writing on the
north african slave trade the
mediterranean all that was like you just
said listen want to be clear slavery bad
i think we both agree right now put
words in your yeah and nobody has done
it for a long time in our families if
they ever did it yeah
i don't want to misspeak i do have a
great i do have a grandmother who is
just kind of a [ __ ] so i don't know
yeah so i don't know
she's dead she's wondering she's fine uh
she so i did want to talk about a lot of
people we missed this because we were
discussing the libs of tiktok story
while this was happening but it was
amazing to see the actual surge in
search traffic meaning people were
looking for the story and it's very hard
to find accurate reporting on the story
these are we have a i think we have a
montage here regarding the uh islamic
riots in sweden for people who don't
know uh if i'm not mistaken it's someone
running for office
who allegedly burnt burned the quran
yeah well i was just saying it to so
that people don't bomb me but thanks uh
i mean i think you're allowed to say
somebody burned the crown yes without
people burning you right of course i'm
also quite sure that i've accidentally
burned a quran yeah
strike anywhere matches quran not a good
place to start do you do you remember
that also there was a flushing the quran
down the lavatory story some years ago
it was claimed at guantanamo bay that
that the
american officer flashed the koran and
my friend mark stein
wrote a piece the next day titled my
quran won't flash yes yes there's no way
it can get around the u-bend no well we
also did a sketch where you know um we
uh uh well uh bob ross uh painted
muhammad oh yes and that one got us into
quite a bit of trouble um
i didn't care very much so here we have
a clip of the riots that were taking
place in sweden over the burning of a
quran and then we'll get back to it for
context
fury at the authorities the police
targeted by protesters in this
residential area in norshooping several
vehicles were set on fire at least 17
people were arrested flashpoints have
stemmed from a series of organized
rallies since thursday led by the leader
of a danish far-right political party
currently on tour in sweden inflammatory
events that include the actual burning
or threat of burning of the quran
and it's war in the west author douglas
murray it's available i assume it's
available on amazon for as long as they
absolutely were you about to say
something right from those videos no i
was going to say um i actually mentioned
that that
quran burning always leads to that yes
and there's always if you remember in
america when that
florida pastor said he might burn a
quran he got a call for david petraeus
asking him not to like if you if you're
in america and you want to burn a crime
you can get straight to the top of the
pentagon yeah within within hours um
by contrast uh i think two years ago it
was reported in some of the press that
some bibles have been burned in portland
oregon at a antifa
protest and this was immediately
denounced by various people as being
russian propaganda and much more and
eventually the new i cited the new york
times
looks into it finally and says well it
is possible that some bibles were burnt
but they were only used as kindling
but like i mean nobody goes bananas yeah
over that
nobody i mean they've already burnt down
portland so you don't need to burn it no
exactly i was going to say but they must
have been looking hard for kindling yeah
they
they've run out to go to the old
courthouse just pull off the old north
wall i tell you there is not much left
yeah destroying that
so anyhow but the point is is that no
nobody uh in the west no no christian uh
goes nuts about this uh it's only with
the crown it's only with islam well it's
also very physical right when people
this is also why the idea of um you know
dipping bullets in like bacon grease
when people used to talk about their war
on turrets because uh when you have are
dealing sometimes in that situation with
would-be terrorist martyrs um the only
language they would speak is is shame
and so they believe in a very physical
manifestation of heaven that you go
through the body you have here and so
the quran is very important too it's
very physically holy whereas for us it's
just
it's just it's a communication device
for we don't think god isn't the bible
it's just a thing but we have we have in
most of the west we've completely just
agreed to the terms of islamic blasphemy
i mean we just have yeah uh
some years ago i just mentioned last
time but like
we used to speak each year
every five years the reunion of the
danish cartoons
controversy and by the last time there
was a anniversary i think the 10th
anniversary not only would none of the
papers including the paper that
originally published the cartoons
published them again
but the only place in denmark which it
was safe because they had another attack
on a free speech event just before the
only place safe enough to have our event
was the danish parliament because it's
the only building with walls thick
enough to withstand a bomb
so um so so walls work so walls away
castle walls like those of of the
christians borg in in copenhagen but the
point is is that we've basically uh
conceded this point yeah that
you shouldn't
you shouldn't insult muhammad you
shouldn't draw muhammad you've got to go
on those terms you've got to call in the
prophet and all that stuff and the price
they've made the price of not doing that
quite high and occasionally people like
this danish politician try to make this
point it's just you know it's never done
in an ideal way but you know it's always
that uh it's it's that thing well see i
just i that's just that's the difference
i think between just trying to and i
totally support his right to do it just
trying to incite some sort of
controversy whereas well i did the quran
challenge back in 2009 uh i did a three
stooges routine of muhammad beating his
two wives his six-year-old wife and uh
we did the the bob ross now the idea is
that's pretty funny the idea was bob
ross is so tone-deaf he doesn't realize
he's all jovial he's painting muhammad
to me that's funny but i don't need to
uh agree with the reasoning that anyone
is doing it but i will say it makes it
very difficult for people like me
to stand out there and just treat islam
as you would any other religion in the
realm of comedy when everyone else is
terrified of it it makes it really
difficult it really does like you say it
creates
this almost mass hypnosis there's a
terrific dutch comedian called hans
taywin
and uh he has a line in one of his
recent shows he said he said uh people
say to me why don't you take the mickey
out of islam like you do uh with other
religions and i say to them but what is
funny about islam
when i think of islam i just think of
joate vivre
yeah yeah yeah very well they're happy
folk um i mean and if not you know like
the good thing is they get to take it
out on their their broads so they
relieve the old tension loosen the
shoulders um do you think
as someone who defines yourself as a
christian atheist we can discuss that
there on mod club if we on the
disagreement but uh going with that
premise do you think that
islam meaning
actual islam not people who've left the
faith or sort of secularists who've
who at one point were muslim
ben dr ben carson do a lot of flack for
this where he said that the quran is not
compatible with the constitution but
that was effectively echoing the idea
that um
the quran and sharia law are not
compatible with western civilization
do you think that's an accurate
assessment
well it's it's not compatible if you're
trying to put the same the laws of the
crown in place obviously not right i
mean obviously not but i think there
might be misunderstanding about that
which is can it work underneath the law
of the land well obviously it does
because lots of muslims just peaceful
and go about their daily life with their
beliefs it would only be if you tried to
impose the laws of it on america of
course it wasn't but that brings us to a
problem doesn't it anywhere that you
have a majority muslim it does become
the law of the land and so that's where
people talk about well that's that's
what no that's what i got into some
trouble about over a couple of books
about the strange death of europe was
that
subtitled immigration identity in islam
and
what everyone
what my critics hated about about the
book
was that
i kept coming back to this point which
is that
when a number of believers get above a
certain level
the question of compatibility stops
becoming abstract right like you have to
hope that you've got lots of unbelievers
or not devout people because if you were
to get a certain percentage of devout
people then obviously the customs of
your own country are going to change and
they'd have to because the people have
changed right so um but but that's among
among all the unpopular points i've ever
managed to make in my life
going into that one is one of the least
popular people hate the idea that
somebody moves from one country to
another and doesn't immediately take on
all of the values of the country they've
moved to right well that's the issue
here really in the united states right
they're an extreme uh
extreme minority uh muslims yeah to the
general population but the concern is
anywhere you look where there's an
islamic country sharia does become the
law of land which is very different by
the way
we judeo-christian principles and i
think that you um i don't know if you
read about it in this book but i know
that you've talked about it at length
inform
the values that are the foundation of
the law of this country it's not a there
isn't a biblical prescription right for
you know the laws of a society that
might consider itself a part of modern
christendom the quran is different
because it is just as much a set of
political beliefs values and a set of
rules yeah as it is uh a religion and
that's where yeah that's always a
different problem yeah it's a political
project as well as a religion and um
people can avoid the political project
and just be involved in the sort of
spiritual part but um
yeah i mean it's a case in majority
muslim countries across the middle east
and far east that you know
if you actually try to enact what's
there it's um it's not a happy situation
i don't know if they can though i don't
know with islam compared to you know
a lot of sort of the eastern rel whether
it's like buddhism taoism or you know um
what i uh very you know colloquially
refer to as the inconsequential
religions
uh
that uh you know i don't know that you
can just sort of do tantric yoga and you
know okay it's just something like
dabbling islam is not really something
you dabble in no if you dabble and you
go in and out
the prescription is for you to be killed
well most western people don't
understand that you see most western
people again they think that um you
might do islam you might do yoga it's
kind of the same thing right
and uh it's been a certain amount of my
life when you know that's not the case
yeah whereas i can be a christian and
still touch my toes
they're not they're not incompatible you
know what when we go to the mud club
extended that's he asked me he came in
he was very polite he said now is that
uh is that a colored water i said no
that's hard liquor
we're not subject to the fcc rules so
afterwards yeah you'll get me to do a do
a nice uh uh what is a happy baby pose i
don't know one thing i do like though i
was reading about this islam you know
what look credit where it's due child
rapists get crucifixion execution mm-hmm
that's come on
that's not positive that one's not bad
for child rapists i'm just saying you
know i mean i don't know i mean i'd take
like burning them in a cage
but
um let me ask you this though while
we're talking about
uh throwing him off a rooftop i'm just
saying something something for child
rapists the rehabilitation rate is uh
is very very low um but a lot of people
are sort of talking about this this sin
of
of western civilization slavery you know
i was just watching actually have you
been watching on hbo winning time the uh
uh the lakers story it's pretty good
apparently not very accurate but one of
the players was going on this monologue
in the in the uh show he was speaking to
the actor who portrays kareem
abdul-jabbar and talking about how uh
this the sin of slavery in
america and how they look at black
people and how you know my mother used
to say mom
uh my mom used to say god loves you but
i would say why did we start at the
bottom and she said well that's because
god loves white people more and it was a
screed about slavery and i'm sitting
there going like okay almost any film
i've heard that in every photo i've seen
in the last 10 years well that i didn't
say was particularly deep no but it's in
sort of the public uh the public mind
right now and every time i watch it i go
well yeah that's terrible obviously if
you're talking about slavery he's
talking about ancestors who grew up on a
cotton uh in the cotton fields picking
cotton but
it's still happening
and um there are 40 million slaves in
the world today which is more than there
were in the 19th century yes exactly
that's a number that people didn't
believe and we make our references
publicly available because they thought
that can't be right sort of like there
are more trees now than in
any point in the 19th century uh and
when people understand that a big reason
for that is modern sort of mega farm so
a lot of the land after you know really
we were a sedentary lifestyle right the
agricultural revolution before the
industrial revolution everyone had a
farm now very few people have a farm
that's taken up with trees so when
people do a little bit of diving into it
they go okay i guess that makes sense uh
but particularly the islamic world yeah
well i i i make this point and i just
i'm very keen to get this out there
because americans americans
think in particular think they're
uniquely guilty and everyone else was
uniquely innocent right they don't know
that every single civilization in
history had slavery of some form yes and
if we start to tear down everything that
was created by slaves we're going to
have to like remove the the pyramids in
egypt i mean that was not done by people
who are paid a fair day's wage no the
aliens don't accept minimum wage
i've watched the history
but but you you know there is there's
this thing in america where
not only are people injected with this
idea that they specifically did it and
other but they also they have no context
of what happened in the rest of the
world right they don't know that if if
up to 12 million people were taken
across the atlantic in the transatlantic
slave trade most not to america remember
right um
but maybe up to 18 million one eight
million were taken east in this in the
slave trade of
black africans selling their brothers
and sisters eastwards to the arabs why
do we not know about this because the
arabs castrated all the males so there
would be no next generation of black
africans in their area right this was
actually a genocidal slave trade which
is a transatlantic slave trade for all
its appallingness was not it did not
intend to annihilate the people right
which to work make them make them force
them to work
but i mean nobody knows this about the
arab slave trade and and i'm not trying
and when i make this point people say oh
that's what a battery it isn't what a
battery is what we used to call context
yes and in an era where the american
public are being told you know reframe
your founding date to 1619 so you can
feel more guilty
um let's you know talk endlessly about
something that was settled two centuries
ago as if we still haven't addressed it
i mean you get these ignoramuses now
come out in america we've never had this
discussion
we had this discussion again and again
problem is you don't know about it right
and it's
things not happening
is not the case just because you're
ignorant exactly um but but i'm very
keen that people get out of this because
this thing of saying to one group of
people and again that the majority
you're guilty you have to say no no
american alive today is guilty of the
slave trade by the way also they don't
have inherited guilt if we're going to
go into the concept of inherited guilt
let's do inherited guilt for everybody
let's go and find who in africa is
guilty
because their ancestors sold their
neighbors let's find out who in america
is descended from slaves and slavers
let's if you want to do this this is
going to be the ugliest damn exercise
you've ever tried
they're talking now about reparations
again in the united states without
realizing you know this is a country
where it appears to be outrageous to
demand somebody shows id when they go to
the voting booth
and they and they're talking about
working out who is owed reparations for
something that happened to their
ancestors 200 years ago right
and and so this is one thing can't
stress it enough americans and others
have to stop falling for this thing of
inherited guilt you're not guilty for
anything you didn't do you're guilty for
things you did yourself but again going
back to the christian ethic the sins of
the father we the sins of the father
ethic is a is is
deemed to be wrong for all sorts of
reasons but the sins of the great great
great great could have possibly done
something father ethic
no way no way no i think it's a very
good point um and i just think that i
think the context is important i think
you know you just said
you use the term ignoramuses which is a
much nicer way of saying uh [ __ ] um
wankers also yes wankers though that has
a sexual connotation that i just think
you need to have a sexual connotation
well i prefer to have a sexual
connotation but uh it is one of those uh
situations where like you said these
people are ignorant there was recent um
polling i don't remember when we
addressed it in the show uh the
reference will be available on some show
map but uh that showed you know
generation x
and older millennials were the least
racist of the generations and then
younger millennials in generation z
were and by racist i mean willing to
identify people primarily through being
racially conscious believing you know
perceiving the discriminatory slights
based on race uh more than generation x
or older millennials because in our
generation we've talked about this you
know i did grow up in people say it's
just because you're white no it's not
you know because i had friends who were
black and we watched the same show right
same yeah and same here the people
actually
and you didn't say my black friend no
you didn't yeah and
then you have a gap and now you have
kids where it's been revived and like i
said so they don't know that this
conversation has taken place and we sort
of said all right so now we get okay
fresh prince the biggest name in all of
cinema and television is going to be
will smith and we're we're going to be
watching and consuming black culture i
think i mean for crying look at the
collaboration efforts that have taken
place between hip-hop artists uh and and
punk rock artists i think was it pearl
jam and i don't know anyway they they
this there's a generation that's that's
got a totally wrong view of what this
society is what the western societies
are
um
you know when i was growing up in
britain in the 80s you know the main
evening news was read on on the main
channel by a very famous black female
broadcaster and the main news on the
other channel was read by a famous black
male broadcaster we we didn't lack black
representation at all we were perfectly
used to it this generation has come
along now that doesn't know any of this
they don't know that like
they think that black people were
completely absent from the public square
until they came along yeah and it's flat
around and you can prove now that in
america in particular you have a
generation that is absolutely
ill-informed about the country they're
in look at these these cases of um
of of uh moral panics on campuses i mean
you'll be familiar with them but i mean
you know there's
i do a section on the book on this and
there's this one there's one one of the
universities they they
somebody says that they've spotted a
member of the kkk on campus the campus
goes into lockdown this is in 2016 the
campus goes into lockdown
they find the person it turns out to be
a dominican monk carrying a rosary the
person who spotted the kkk person claims
he was carrying a whip it's a dominican
monk with a rosary
this turns out this is not a one-off
this is quite common in the last decade
in american campuses they're going to
lock down one goes into lockdown when a
um a pair of shoelaces is found a wet
shoelace is found hanging on a hook and
somebody says this is an attempted
lynching it isn't somebody found a
shoelace and they put it up there
my point is this happens again and again
and again and why is it it seems that
there is a part at least of this
generation that's coming up that
believes that they live in a country
where the kkk routinely gather on
campuses or just wander alone you know
yeah you know when i was in uh seattle a
little while ago they had the whole
foods what was left of it had a great
big sign up saying racists are not
welcome here well we didn't think that
it was a gathering place for the clan
right what what's what's what's the view
you've got of your country that is so
off yeah no and you know who's probably
more responsible for uh racists in 2022
than the clan
tyler perry and i'm only saying that
half joking because obviously the
content is crap but you know we had uh
uh family matters we'd have fresh
principles it was very mixed and now
you've siloed bet and tyler perry this
is the black channel and it's the white
channel and you know what you don't and
a big part of that is you don't want to
culturally appropriate and so you have
people who are afraid to take part in
each other's cultures and so really now
we've created just like we have with
music just like we have with television
in general right sort of the consumption
of entertainment everything is
fragmented
we've
sectioned people off yes and they and
they now do this thing of this like it's
the worst is in the publishing industry
in a way uh which that may sound
verified but i can tell you
people say uh there aren't enough um
people of color represented and there
aren't enough trans people being
published
every publishing house is scouring the
land for any transsexual they can find
to publish a memoir yeah i'm like
this is this is this is bonanza
publishing decade if you're trans yeah
or if you're a woman or if you're a
person of color it's quite it's
completely the opposite of the way it's
portrayed and and the part of that is
they they don't even know
they don't even know that black people
have a very very rich history of
publishing and writing books before they
came along to save them and suddenly
force people into the publishing
industry
it's it's it's a complete
misunderstanding of the past and the
present and it's just
i don't know how you course correct
people who've got a completely wrong
vision of everything up till themselves
and also misunderstand their own era
well i think i think you're doing your
part and i will say i think uh
someone like you can do a certain amount
and the only language that i think these
people speak um for example we're just
talking about the language of shame with
uh with jihadists
is uh embarrassment is turning them into
a mockery a lot of these that's why they
hate the term social justice worry the
term woke and then they try it they're
trying to reappropriate it back they
can't stand being made into a mockery
that's why they go after comedians so
hard when you think about it the
christian right
they didn't even really go after like
south park when south park
they just didn't want it on at night and
south park uh uh
stone and parker they said oh we don't
think that we should be on in prime time
we think that we should be on at 11 to
midnight or somewhere around there there
was no disagreement yeah they haven't
gone after there have been some but not
amass like you're seeing now with
whoever it is dave chappelle bill bird
take your pick that given week dave um
that so so there's you know me and dave
kind of doing our part is just okay the
only language i think that they speak
effectively is mockery unfortunately
there's been only academics on the right
sort of balancing it because we've
conceded a lot of that territory
culturally
um well it's not just conceding at
cultural that's true it's also i mean
basically there is just fear in the
culture yeah i mean like we were talking
earlier about islam and there was fear
around islam i mean a certain gender
they blow [ __ ] up they blow [ __ ] up they
actually might kill you
and um
and so so it's quite easy to create fear
um what is going on in the west at the
moment about the west is is generated by
fear and basically what you know i the
analogy i use for this is
it's the the the woke left of operating
like a shepherd with a sheepdog if
you've ever seen that masterful thing
that happens in order to make the herd
move in the direction you want you don't
have to you don't the dog doesn't run
right into the middle of the herd right
you run to the outer edges of the herd
and you nip right now that's what's
happening in our society particularly in
america they're they are trying to
police the entire herd by getting the
people they see as being at the margins
that's where they come and have it have
a have a nip dave chappelle that's why
they they try to bite joe rogan that's
why they come for comedians because
if if these people eyes were taught a
lesson
the rest of us are taught a lesson too
right
[ __ ] that yes
i appreciate and i appreciate you like
half saying it but then still saying
[ __ ]
um
what do you think they didn't hear this
i just suddenly remember well can i you
know sometimes you're on television and
you can't say that words oh you're not
on television we're not that important i
mean the
ratings are higher but it might get you
demonetized isn't that possible
sometimes i'm already i've been
demonetized for years of course you have
yeah of course what did you think
this is this is all this is all f and by
the way this is all funded by mug club
members uh not a foreign caliphate
surprisingly enough what were you gonna
say is it going to get me banned or i
don't care say it no no no
generally you're going to say that it's
there are lots of platforms where they
can if they don't say certain things no
but we're we're past that aren't we yeah
i mean you know truth is funny what's
funny is i've never been what people say
like a blue comedian i've always said
the show is like a strong kind of a
pg-13
i don't really like you know vulgarity
for vulgarity sake i've always liked
suggestive humor but things that needle
people or someone says you can't say
that things that are offensive yeah i've
always found inherently funny
yeah of course and that is the thing
you're told not to laugh at is always
the funniest thing right obviously and
you know what's funny you mentioned that
the sort of sheep dogs and this this
herding um
which i was just talking about this
recently because i have a friend and
i've done a little bit of like sort of
dog training a as sort of more of a
hobby but we've had dog trainers come in
you've met joe lewis a dog that big and
that powerful uh if you don't have him
in line it's a problem you know someone
has a chihuahua they bite you whatever
he bites somebody i'm on the nightly
news
and uh they're particularly used yes yes
exactly well he has a bite pressure of
500 psi like a pit bull is about 300.
and a german shepherd only be like 250.
so they're bred for hunting boar and for
defending the farms from puma mountain
lion cougar and um
the funny thing is though he has a 500
pound bite pressure
and uh he got attacked recently by a
german shepherd like puncture wounds and
i've told this story on air where they
actually had to take him to the vet and
squeeze out the infection all the stuff
this poor guy
he grabbed it by the neck because it's
what they do joel is for people who
don't know a dog argentino uh they'll
run out grab it by the neck and rag doll
it put it down traditional boar hunters
then you would kill it with a knife
he didn't leave a scratch on this german
shepherd even though he could have
crushed its neck and windpipe and it's
that bridled power and so while they
kind of go they want to nip and they
want to hurt because that really is the
only tool they have dogs that are
hurting dogs that's what they're bred to
do that's we have to be careful with
them and children sometimes because
they'll nip children not in a mean way
but to get them inside
whereas a joe lewis they know better
than too it's like i don't want to
destroy the kill right well by the way i
don't stress i want to rag all them but
i don't want to just i don't want to
kill them that's what i'm saying i would
also like to have my dog attack i don't
stretch this analogy but
let me risk it
one of my contentions at the moment is
that is that people in the west
particularly white westerners have
been in a very strange position in
recent years we've been
we've been what i describe as polite and
courteous yes
so somebody says um you know you have
your culture we have ours and we say
that's great charming and then we end up
overdoing it we say what a wonderful
culture you have
it's better than ours
it's a form of politeness and there's a
lot to be said for it i mean courtesy is
an important part of civilization
but it can't be limitless
and
my view is that we're around some kind
of tipping point where people's um
patience might be coming to an end and i
sort of think it should come to an end
yes of saying
you know i'm willing to have a certain
amount of course correction but not
total decimation right so i'm not having
you take all of our heroes away i'm not
having you come for everybody in our
history who we admire
um i'm especially not having that whilst
you have nothing to offer in this place
so for instance i have one of my
obsessions is this one with cultural
appropriation do you notice the people
who talk about cultural appropriation
always talk about it in the most stupid
unimportant terms like oh halloween
costumes yeah most of culture isn't
about bloody halloween costumes right
you know uh the braiding of hair is
cultural appropriation okay what about
music
right who's allowed to borrow what are
the boundaries
are we allowed to borrow across uh
cultural boundaries or do some cultures
have to keep absolutely absolutely like
hermetically sealed for racial reasons
yeah now of course they haven't thought
about it which is why they're obsessing
with the stupid halloween costumes each
year they haven't thought about it
because it is absolutely impossible this
idea the point with western culture was
that we didn't appropriate we
appreciated other cultures we went out
and found them and when we admired them
we brought it into our own culture
there's nothing to be shamed about about
that there's nothing to be ashamed about
so at some point
in the current era it has to be possible
to turn around and say i'm sorry i'm
done with feeling guilt i'm done with
apologizing for things i didn't do i'm
done with being told i should feel shame
for things i'm done with being told that
there's nothing good about my culture or
my history or my background and here's a
standoff you don't respect my ancestors
and my culture why should i respect
yours no i think you're absolutely right
i would i think that cultural
appropriation could be a good thing for
example if in the middle east they you
know appropriated uh freedom and no
longer having slavery yeah i'd like all
right you can take that's like consider
that our taco tuesday for you guys it
will give you uh rights for fifty
percent of the population yes exactly
it's a swap though i think that just
ends up being another form of slavery
i'm not entirely sure i want to talk
about the differing views sort of in the
uk and the united states here as we go
to mud club because uh being raised in
canada uh it's really it's it's really
just they they want to be american so
desperately even though they have the
queen on their money that uh it might be
a little bit different from uh where you
were raising you mentioned america quite
a bit the book is the war in the west
douglas murray we're about to talk about
some things that uh well i'll just say
this i don't know what he's going to say
i'm not a mind reader but i assume
things that couldn't be permitted here
on youtube you can feel free to get me
demonetized all you want once you get
the mug club youtube
piss off
[Music]
you